in the last video we had set up the
definite integral to evaluate the volume
of this this upside-down gumdrop truffle
looking thing so now in this video we
can actually evaluate the definite
integral so what we need to do is really
just expand out this this expression the
square root of y plus 1 plus 2 so let's
do that so this is going to be equal to
PI times the definite integral from Y is
equal to negative 1/2 Y is equal to 3 if
you expand this out you get square root
of y plus 1 squared which is just going
to be Y plus 1 and then you're going to
have 2 times the product of both of
these terms 2 times 2 times square root
of y plus 1 is going to be plus 4 times
the square root of y plus 1 and then you
have 2 squared so plus 4 so you have
this whole thing times dy we can
simplify a little bit you have a 1 plus
a 4 we can add the 1 to the 4 and get a
5 and now we're ready to take the
antiderivative so this is going to be
equal to PI times let's take the
antiderivative of all of this business
PI times pi times and I'll color code it
the antiderivative of Y is just Y
squared over 2 the antiderivative of 4
times the square root of y plus 1 you
just really have to think of it as 4
times y plus 1 to the 1/2 power we could
use u-substitution explicitly but you
probably are pretty practising this can
do this in your head you have y plus 1
raised to the one half power derivative
of y plus 1 is just 1 which is
essentially out here so you can really
just if you did use substitution you
would call you'd say u is equal to y
plus 1 but this antiderivative is going
to be equal to well if you increment
this exponent you get 3 halves x the
reciprocal 2/3 2/3 times 4 is 8 thirds
so it's plus 8/3 times y plus 1 to the
three-halves and you can verify if you
take the derivative here you will get
this expression right over here
three-halves times 8 thirds is 4
decremented you have y plus 1 to the 1/2
power
and then finally you have finally you
have let's see what color if I not used
yet finally you have this 5 the
antiderivative of 5 is just 5 y 5 y and
we are evaluating it
we are going to evaluate it from at
three and at negative one y is equals 3
and y equals negative one so this is
going to be equal to PI so let's
evaluate all this business at 3 so 3
squared over 2 is 9 halves 3 plus 1 is 4
to the three-halves
well that's let's see if square root of
4 is 2 to the third power is 8 8 times 8
thirds is 64 over 3 so plus 64 over 3
you have 5 times 3 well that's going to
be 15 plus 15 and from that we're going
to subtract all this business evaluated
at negative 1 so you have negative 1
squared over 2 well that's just 1/2
negative 1 plus 1 is 0 to the 3 1/2
power that's going to be 0 times 8
thirds is all going to be 0 so we don't
have to even write it and then finally
you have negative 1 times 5 well this is
going to be negative 5 negative 5 and we
are in the homestretch we really just
have to do a little bit of arithmetic
add some add some hairy fractions right
over here so let's do it so this whole
thing is going to simplify to PI times
and it looks like let's see or at least
common multiple of all of these
denominators is going to be 6 so let's
put everything over a denominator of 6
so 9 halves is the same thing as 27 over
660 4/3 is the same thing as 128 over 6
15 15 is the same thing as 90 over 6 90
over 6 1/2 is the same thing as 3 over 6
so this is distribute the negative signs
this is negative 3 6 and you just and
negative times negative is positive 5 is
the same thing as 30 over 6 so plus plus
30 over 6 and so this is going to give
us our denominator is going to be over 6
we're going to multiply something times
pi we have this PI over here and then we
just have to figure out the numerator is
so let's see if I can do this in let's
see if I can do this in my head so 27
plus 1 28 27
Plus 128 is going to be let me see
that's going to be 140 155 is that right
155 is let's see if we get to 48 plus
another seven yet 155 plus 90 gets us to
245 is that right yeah plus 96 to 245
minus 3 you subtract 3 from that you get
to 242 and then you add 32 that you get
to - 72 - 72 so we are left with 272 PI
over 6 but then we can let's see - 72 +
6 are both divisible by 2 so this is
equal to C - 72 divided by 2 is going to
be 1 1 36 PI over and if you divide this
denominator right over here by 2 over 3
is that right yeah 136 PI over 3 and 136
is not divisible by 3 so we have it as
simplified as we can this right over
here is the volume of our little
upside-down gumdrop looking thing